Martha Bayles: I too have a slight cold. I
warn you. I don't know if there's a cough
button on this thing. I'll try to find it.
Thank you to Larry Arnn and to Tim Caspar,
to Doug Jeffrey and Matt Bell and Mary Jo
Von Ewegen and also Kim Ellsworth, who helped
me negotiate my departure from snowy Boston
yesterday. Ninety-five inches of snow and
counting. I'm a New Englander. I just think
it's great. This is not just a cold and wintry
season in America. It's also an election season
coming up. I get that feeling from some of
the speakers. I'd like to start with that.
If you ask yourself what is the most important
thing about the upcoming American election,
I'm sure everyone here will have their answers.
Many other Americans will have other answers.
The answer is different outside this country.
Ninety-five percent of the people in the world
are not Americans. To those people, for billions
of them, billions of them, the most important
thing about the American election is that
the winning party is not going to round up
the losing party and put them in jail, however
much they might want to.
I gave a talk in China before the last Presidential
election at a Chinese university. I think
it was Fudan University in Shanghai. One of
the students asked who was going to be the
next American President. I said that I didn't
know. I could tell from their faces, or at
least I thought I could, and from some comments
I got afterward that they just figured I wasn't
a very important person because if I was an
important person, I would know who was going
to be the next President. I picked up on that
and I said, "Nobody knows."
They were incredulous. I felt obliged to explain
that a little bit, that it actually was a
contest, and that the winning party was not
going to put the losing party in jail. I could
see the smile on the face of my host, who
was a very experienced and a very wise foreign
service officer, who was very happy to see
this slipped into a lecture that was actually
supposed to be about something else.
This message is not really getting out there
these days, these kinds of messages. When
95 percent of humanity, well make that 90
percent because I think there's probably another
5 who do know America pretty well and do understand
these things. Maybe even 10 percent. Let's
say 85 to 90 percent of the people in the
world, when they look at America and its elections
and other things, what do they see? I'll give
you a little taste of what a lot of them see.
This is true everywhere in the world, including
Europe.
In early 2001, the State Department did one
of its rare follow-up studies of international
visitors. They have a fairly robust international
visitors program but they rarely do follow-up
studies, which is sort of odd, but that's
the way people do evaluation in Washington
these days. They commissioned a follow-up
study of 60 Mexicans who had been brought
here in an international visitor's program
in late 2000, early 2001.
Here is part of the report's summary of what
the visitors had to say about the difference
between the Americans they met when they were
here and the Americans that they saw on their
television screens and movie screens. I quote,
"People who watch US television shows, attend
Hollywood movies, and listen to pop music
can't help but believe that we are a nation
in which we have sex with strangers regularly.
We wander the streets well-armed and fully
prepared to shoot our neighbors at the slightest
provocation and the lifestyle to which we
aspire is one of rich cocaine snorting." This
was before the release of Wolf of Wall Street.
The report continues, "This is not an accurate
depiction of the United States, nor is it
attractive to many people around the world.
The Mexican visitors were very clear that
their images of America, shaped by commercial
entertainment media, were inaccurate and distorted
and gave them a negative perception of the
United States." This was from one of our closest
neighbors before 9/11. When they asked me
to set up an election debate, which they're
not going to do, this is a question I would
like to see debated in the upcoming election.
This is a more general question but it relates
to the rest of my talk. I would like to see
the Democrats speak about what they think
government cannot and should not do. I'm sure
you all would like to hear that too. I would
also like to ask the Republican candidates
what they think government can and should
do. It would be very interesting to hear if
people have to actually answer those questions.
Now the starting point of my book, Through
A Screen Darkly, and yes it's an illusion
to Paul, is that when the Cold War ended,
the United States government got out of the
business of representing the United States
to the rest of the world.
They allowed the job by default, by semi-conscious
decision, to be taken over by the entertainment
industry. This was a decision that was made
gradually over the '90's, culminating in the
termination of the USIA in 1999, that would
be the US Information Agency, which was a
semi-autonomous agency that used to handle
what is called public diplomacy around the
world. It was bi-partisan. It was made with
very little debate.
As one conservative veteran of USIA put it
to me, he said, "That was a piece of bipartisan
bad judgment." My talk today will have three
parts. The first is to look at the current
crisis in US public diplomacy and to say a
little bit about how it developed over time
and why it happened the way it did, briefly,
very briefly. Second to talk about the role
of exported popular culture; our Hollywood
films, our TV shows, our popular music, in
deepening the crisis, the crisis being of
America's reputation. Third to talk about
what would be required as a solution, or what
would be required as part of a solution.
To talk about the first part, I would just
briefly summarize what I have distilled as
the purposes of public diplomacy. The term
public diplomacy was coined in the early '60's
as a substitute for propaganda, which had
acquired a rather negative connotation during
the course of the 20th Century. I'll say a
little bit more about why it's different from
propaganda, which I strongly feel it's different
from propaganda. It has three main things
that public diplomacy does.
The first is it reports the news in a responsible,
accurate, comprehensive, fair and thorough
way in parts of the world where the media
are strongly censored or strongly biased or
simply undeveloped. It provides news, especially
local and regional news, to parts of the world
where there's only a state service or there's
only a very propagandist local news. This
is the history of Radio Free Europe, Radio
Liberty, Radio of Free Asia, which began in
the '90's. Some other of our broadcast entities
claim to be doing this. It's not clear to
me they are.
That's a very important ... I think it's the
politically most acceptable right now function
of public diplomacy because as I'm sure you
know, other governments in the world, notably
Russia and China and others, and Iran and
others, are spending huge amounts of money
on not only broadcasting within their own
countries but broadcasting in the region,
in other languages, and around the world in
a kind of CNN style English language headline
news, Russia Today being the most prominent
example of it. Russia Today now broadcasts
in most of the world in English, Spanish,
Arabic, and one other language which is escaping
me at the moment. Oh, Mandarin. Mandarin.
We of course do nothing very much like that
right now.
Number two, to present what Harry Truman called
a full and fair picture of American society,
history, culture and institutions. Here I
would also emphasize political institutions
and political traditions. This is really not
being done at all now. It's unfortunate. You
might wonder whether the government is capable
of doing it. I think that's a very valid question.
All I can say is it's not going to be done
by the commercial sector because there's really
not much money in it. The same goes for reporting
the news in Uzbekistan or in the mountain
region between Pakistan and Afghanistan. You're
not going to make a lot of money doing that.
You're not going to make a lot of money broadcasting
in a lot of places. Who's going to do it?
It's not going to be done by the commercial
sector.
Third is another one that's a big problematic
which is to advocate for the United States,
for its ideals, for its intentions in your
part of the world or the world in general,
and its interests. In other words, to explain
foreign policy. Of course you have to have
a foreign policy that can be explained. To
have the responsibility of explaining it to
the rest of the world and with the feedback
that comes with that, might actually be an
added incentive to actually have a coherent
foreign policy. Who knows? The decline of
public diplomacy was, as I said, gradual.
It started actually before the end of the
Cold War, with the so-called Culture Wars
and the counter-culture of the '60's and the
Vietnam War.
With the divisions that arose in American
society, a lot of people who had formerly
been very helpful with the USIA and very willing
to go on tours and give lectures and be part
of that effort, academics, journalists, artists,
writers, went pretty far to the left for the
most part, became alienated from doing propaganda
for the government. There's many, many occasions
I could describe to you of this happening.
Meanwhile, when President Reagan came in and
made the wonderful and colorful Charles Z.
Wick head of USIA, there was a real push to
make US public diplomacy a really finely honed
Cold War weapon. That mattered. I know some
people who did that. It was good work and
they did it well for the most part. That,
in some ways, furthered the divisions.
It was seen as propaganda by some of its critics
and sometimes it was. Then came the end of
the Cold War. USIA was, you might say, an
exhausted agency. It had really done a lot.
It was not under great leadership. When Jesse
Helms decided to cut a lot of US government
agencies, including the National Endowment
for the Arts and all these other ones that
were really in his sights, the only one that
actually went down was the USIA. That happened
in 1999. Even before that, there had been
serious cuts in all of these programs, including
educational exchanges, cultural exchanges,
things that were seen as not directly relevant
to the ideological battle.
I would make the argument that those things
are crucial, even though they don't necessarily
move the needle of public opinion in foreign
countries in a way that you can discern over
a matter of weeks or months. They build up
connections and relationships and channels
of communication that are there in a crisis.
Similarly with the news, it's a slow build-up
of trust. The people have to know that they're
going to get a reliable sense of what's happening
from the Voice of America or Radio Free Europe.
You can't just drop in and say, "Hi. We're
here with the truthful news" because everybody's
doing that. You have to build up trust over
time. This is a long-term process.
As I say, it looked like a Cold War relic
in the '90's. We needed a peace dividend and
so forth and so on so it got cut. It got cut
rather drastically. At the same time in the
'90's, huge changes in the world. Huge changes
in what would be the practice of this thing.
Very briefly, the first was in media. Even
before the internet, you had the tape cassette.
You had satellite TV, a medium whose importance
is often overlooked in this discussion.
It was satellite TV that penetrated the entire
Middle East, that penetrated huge swaths of
the world that had never seen anything but
their local state TV. A great bulk of it was
entertainment. I'll get to that in a minute.
Then of course came the internet and our beloved
social media. New players, the rise of NGOs
in the '90's was astronomical. Businesses
became more and more involved overseas. Churches
expanded missionary efforts and more short
term kinds of involvement overseas. Universities,
needless to say, have expanded.
Just to sum it up, there's a lot of non-governmental
players who are involved. Some people say,
"Well that is our public diplomacy. This is
America. We don't want the government doing
it. We want all these private sector institutions
and organizations doing it." I think that's
a very cogent argument. I actually went along
with that for a while. When you look at it
from the point of view of other countries,
there's an expectation that the US government
is going to speak and that the US government
will have a voice and it will have a voice
and it will talk to you in Oman or in some
other country, that the US government had
something to say and invites you to listen.
If that government voice isn't there ... I
traveled to 11 countries researching my book.
I must have talked to over 300 individuals
overseas from all different walks of life.
The most consistent complaint was really that
Americans don't pay attention. "They don't
talk to us. They don't listen to us. They
don't care about us." In a world that's supposed
to be anti-American, that's a rather striking
sentiment. I've heard it reflected by many
others. Then of course we had new adversaries,
non-state actors.
Islamic state I would argue is neither Islamic
nor a state. It's certainly not a country.
You may call it totalitarian but it's not
totalitarian in any 20th Century sense because
it's a bunch of roving gangsters, who are
turning upon each other as much upon their
presumed enemies. The Middle East is in a
state of violent and chaotic religious wars.
There's lots of non-state actors there, who
can get their hands on weapons, as was pointed
out earlier this morning. Then you have the
new authoritarian regimes.
You have China and you have Russia and Iran
and some others. They're different from the
Cold War because they deliver, at least China
does and Russia kind of did, they deliver
prosperity to at least a very significant
part of their population. As you know, the
Cold War was as much about prosperity, America's
prosperity, as it was about our freedom and
our way of government. It was about all the
goodies that we had and our comfortable way
of life. It's not about that so much anymore.
It's about something else because the Chinese
Model, as it's so-called, the Beijing Model.
I know it's gotten a little rocky lately,
was that you could have an authoritarian government
and deliver prosperity and you can just administer
the population and control the population
and you don't need any of these messy and
annoying democratic institutions. Give them
bread and circuses and deny them basic political
liberties. Speaking of circuses, the other
thing that happened in the '90's was the explosive
spread of American popular culture, American
entertainment, commercial entertainment, throughout
the world. As these new technologies arose,
notably satellite television, they had to
fill their hours. What did they do? They bought
the worse American soap operas, the Bold and
the Beautiful, all sorts of American programs,
some good.
Don't get me wrong. I've spent most of my
adult life writing about popular culture.
I don't think it's all terrible by any means
or I would have done that. It has changed
in many ways for the worse. I think it's on
a downward trajectory right now. The worst
stuff got out there in all sorts of place
to all sorts of people, in a completely uncontrolled
way.
It's even impossible to measure the full impact
and the full spread because even if you look
at the numbers, which I'll give you in a minute,
they only cover the legal export. Usually
just the legal export to the more lucrative
markets. That ain't the whole world and it
doesn't cover the piracy, the illegal DVDs,
the knock off DVDs, which is a huge industry,
not to mention the internet and all the illegal
downloading that goes on. It's impossible
to measure the spread of this.
I've arrived at my second topic, which is
the impact of our popular culture, our entertainment,
the perceptions of the United States and of
Americans who we are as human beings. Now
one reason why this was allowed to happen
was because of the history of the Cold War.
During the Cold War, American popular culture
was one of America's secret weapons. In fact,
several Russians said after the collapse of
the Soviet Union, many, many Russians testified
to having listened to jazz on the Voice of
America or having later on a younger generation
listening to some rock music, selected rock
music and soul music on the Voice of America.
The power of that music either conveyed by
the governmental channel or just informally
as it just sifted into those countries, was
smuggled in an so forth, was astounding. As
I'm sure a lot of you know, the so-called
Velvet Revolution in Czechoslovakia, one of
the heroic figures or the heroic figures from
that period were a little rock band called
the Plastic People of the Universe. This is
not a rock band you want to sit down and kick
back your heels and listen to their music.
They were more like an absurdist performance
art, which is really not my thing. The thing
about the Plastic People of the Universe in
Prague is they wouldn't stop doing what they
were doing.
The Communist authorities cracked down on
them every conceivable way. They wouldn't
stop doing what they were doing. The just
kept doing what they were doing. After a while,
they attracted the attention of Vaclav Havel
and of his associates, who are more serious
political actors. They became a cult hero.
To this day, if you talk about that little
band in Prague, you will get a response from
people. That was true. We have an uncritical
attitude toward our popular culture at the
end of the Cold War. It was something that
had really made a difference in parts of the
world and a difference for the good. Even
our counter-cultural rock music of the '60's,
which was regarded with loathing at home by
many people, was understood to be subversive
in these foreign settings. You may not like
it here but over there it was pretty subversive,
so it had to be good.
We didn't feel real critical about this. It
was a laissez-faire. Just let it all go out
there. It will bring messages of freedom.
It will bring messages of democracy. I won't
say that it hasn't done that. I will say that
it's carried a lot of other messages with
it along as well. In particular, that Americans
have a taste for the extreme vulgarity, that
American relish extreme and hideous graphic
violence, that we find this very amusing and
we love to watch it and that we are a very
vitriolic people, quite hateful and spiteful
and cynical in our political discourse and
indeed in all of our discourse.
This is all true of course but I use the metaphor
of a fun-house mirror or maybe to update it,
a bad selfie. There's truth to it but it's
grossly exaggerated. It's blown out of proportion.
The good parts of America, the part that offsets
that, the part that after we're through watching
the violent movie we go out and walk down
the street and we don't really think we're
going to get shot at, all that part, the normal
part, the part that's us, airbrushed out.
Our religiosity, airbrushed out. Our civil
society, our institutions, our voluntary organizations,
Hillsdale College, its supporters, people
like you and me, airbrushed out. Not just
conservative people but decent had working
Americans who try to hold their families together
who have certain basic values, airbrushed
out.
Now again, not entirely, not always. I could
give you a list of things that if I were a
culture, I won't say czar, because I think
that words not go over well. If I were in
charge of cultural export, I might consider
I have a list of things I'd like to broadcast.
I'm not sure that's the way to go. Okay well
I won't ... This export of popular culture
expanded very, very drastically. The total
export sales figure for the US entertainment
in 2012 was $35.6 billion. That was an increase
about four-fold from the 1908's. That's the
legal distribution of American popular culture.
Now what is the evidence? What evidence do
I have for making these claims, apart from
all the people I talked to. The people I talked
to have influenced me, I will grant. They've
influenced me a lot. There's also a little
bit of other kinds of evidence. The Pew World
Attitudes Survey, which is a huge sample of
people, over 45,000 people in 47 countries.
No, it's more than that. It's 300 something
thousand people in 47 countries. They do show
that a majority of people in the world, at
least the people they polled, said they like
American movies, music and TV. You can't deny
that. You wouldn't be making all that money
overseas of people didn't like this stuff.
Of course this is disliked in the entire Muslim
majority world, which won't surprise anyone.
It's disliked in Russia. It's disliked in
India, where people are very pro-American.
I could talk about that a little bit. Here's
I think a more interesting finding from Pew.
They find majorities in a great many countries
agreeing with the statement, "It's bad that
American ideas and customs are spreading here."
This is in friendly countries, European countries,
lots of places. I just ask, Pew doesn't ask
this but I do, where do these people get their
impression of American ideas an customs? The
answer is from our popular culture.
Now I start my book with an interview I did
with not a terrorist but a very disruptive
and unpleasant Islamist in Jakarta, in Indonesia,
who goes around with baseball bats breaking
the windows in movie theaters and things like
that. They don't set off bombs but they do
very disruptive things. He spent some time
in Saudi Arabia and brought back a Jubbaiyahist
view of Islam that does not sit well in Indonesia,
where they have their own version of Islam
and they're a very multicultural society.
They don't really cotton to this version of
it.
By the way, there are more Muslims in Indonesia
than in all the Arab countries combined. This
guy is pretty well known in Indonesia. I start
my book with an interview with him. He says
what you'd expect. America is out to destroy
Islam and our culture is one of our weapons.
He believed firmly, as do many ordinary people,
because their own media have always been owned
by the state, they think that this stuff is
coming from the US government. Why wouldn't
they? They don't understand that this is an
independent, privately owned industry in the
United States. It's not true in their country.
It's not true in most countries. They think
the US government is sending them Sex in the
City, along with some other worse things.
You can respond to that guy by saying nothing's
going to change his mind. I think that's true.
Besides, it's the price we pay for freedom.
It's the price we pay for liberty so just
get over it. I think that's the dominant attitude
today in America across the political spectrum.
After I talked to him, I talked to a woman
who works in television in Jakarta. She was
a lovely lady. She was no radical. She was
a religious lady but she didn't cover her
hair. She was middle class, spoke very good
English, just a regular person like you and
me, very smart, very stylish.
She said she was really concerned about how
Indonesian television programs were imitating
American programs and they were having a bad
effect on her kids. It could have been an
American mother talking. It was no different.
She talked about some show that was on during
dinnertime and it showed a woman being strangled
to death on the screen. She said, "I don't
want my kids watching some woman getting strangled
to death on the screen when they're having
dinner." I've heard, throughout my career,
I've heard plenty of Americans express the
same sentiment.
I began my book that way because I'm trying
to show that I'm not worried about what violent
extremists, radicalist, Jihaddist Muslims
think about our culture. I mean they would
condemn Shakespeare as well. I'm worried about
what people like Rossini Salhala thinks, the
lady that I talked to, because there's more
people like her in the world than there are
like Rasique Muhammed, the first man.
Unlike Americans, when these people see some
of our worst material that we export, they
can't adjust the picture. They can't say,
"Well that's Breaking Bad." Not everybody
in Albuquerque is into meth. Not every chemistry
teacher is cooking meth. Not every family
in America is hoarding guns and dead bodies
and all this horrific stuff that goes on in
these programs. Some of them very well-made
programs, I must admit, and entertaining.
We can be entertained by them. We can laugh
at it. We can be offended by it. We can be
perhaps even think that it's a serious show,
that it's trying to make us think about something.
We go about our daily life. We know that's
not really an accurate portrait of our society.
There are billions of people in the world
who cannot do that. They have no way of adjusting
the picture. Now even worse I think, now let
me shift away a little bit, even more concerning
to me as I've thought about this over time,
than the vulgarity and the violence and the
vitriol, is the portrait of American life
and institutions, particularly our political
institutions, our business institutions, our
private sector, our daily life, our communities.
That to me is in some ways more disturbing
because that really speaks ...
I think you can maybe assume the other stuff
is a pandering to the lowest common denominator
and many people in other countries are smart
enough to figure that out. The portrait of
our institutions really bothers me because
it fits all too well with the propaganda of
our enemies. If you hired a PR firm to portray
American society and institutions and culture
in a way that would feed directly into Vladimir
Putin's anti-American propaganda machine,
you could not do better than what most of
what Hollywood is doing these days. There's
just no getting around that.
In Germany, I was in Germany in October giving
a series of lectures. I met some young people,
Germans, who are really into the series I
mentioned a minute ago, Breaking Bad. I expect
there probably aren't too many Breaking Bad
fans in here. Maybe there are. Who knows?
You can read my review in the Claremont Review
of Books. This young man, he was a thoughtful
young man and he was working for one of the
political foundations in Berlin. I asked him,
"Gee you like Breaking Bad. What do you and
your friends get out of that show?"
He said, "Well it's a portrait of how Americans
will do anything for money. It's a portrait
of the desperate straits of Americans and
the lawlessness of America and the drug problems
in America." I said, "we have those kinds
of things in America." You can imagine I argued
with him the way I'm talking to you. He took
it in. I don't know if I made a dent in him.
Another example, House of Cards. How many
of you have watched the American version of
House of Cards. Ah, see, see, okay. Quite
a few. I think it's pretty bad. You can also
read my review of that in the Claremont Review
of Books. It's a slick production. If you
ever spent any time in Washington you will
not recognize what it tries to make Washington
look like. Worst of all, it isn't about what's
wrong in Washington. It's about sort of a
Macbeth story, a conspiracy you know, which
worked really well in the British version
by the way. I recommend the British version
because it was about a struggle within the
conservative party for power. The Macbeth
thing kind of worked.
In the American version, the guy had spent
I think one internship in Washington, as opposed
to the guy who did the British version who
had spent 4 years working in the Thatcher
government or working for Margaret Thatcher
and in the conservative party. One knew a
lot about what he was dealing with, the other
knew practically nothing and it shows. Despite
all this, the show is very popular online
in China, on the Sohu streaming website. Now
when I say very popular, it had a few hundred
million viewers, which is a pittance in China.
Among those viewers included several high
officials in the Chinese Communist Party,
who went around praising the show and recommending
it to their friends. Is this good new or bad?
The old Cold War thing is, "Well Chinese officials
are watching an American TV show. That must
be liberating, right?"
I'm currently sponsoring a Chinese Fulbright
Scholar at Boston College a man from Beijing
who teaches American studies and film at the
Chinese Foreign Studies University in Beijing.
He argues sometimes that every American cultural
export, no matter how awful, is a double edged
sword, including House of Cards, because no
matter how negative the picture, what really
come across is American freedom of expression.
Because he's friends with a lot of the so-called
sixth generation film producers, film directors
in China who are now getting systematically
shut down by President Chi and his administration,
the party. He knows what's happening in China
and he's continually impressed that you can
make such anti-government, such anti-American
films in Hollywood and get away with it. That's
the sort of gut feeling I think a lot of people
in authoritarian societies have to these shows.
There was a villain in the second season of
House of Cards. I hope none of you made it
to the second season. It was even worse than
the first. It was a Chinese villain. This
raised great concern in the Central Department
of Propaganda and Thought Work. I'm not inventing
that name. There were high level meetings
and a writer at the English language China
Daily, and also at People's Daily, the Chinese
language national party newspaper, was commissioned
to write an article explaining that House
of Cards, yes, they had a Chinese villain,
but don't worry the show, and I quote, "Is
actually a strong diatribe against the political
system in the United States." Everybody felt
better.
I guess I've gone on over my time. I was going
to make some points at the end but I look
at my clock with horror. Wait, it's 1:20?
My watch just picked a funny time to stop.
I'm glad there's another clock up here. I'll
keep going. Six weeks ago I took my Chinese
visitor to see The Interview, a show that
was in the headlines recently, a potty-mouthed,
blood-spattered comedy about two hapless American
journalists recruited by the CIA to assassinate
the leader of North Korea, Kim Jong-un, the
dictator of Korea I should say.
Now as you may remember, The Interview was
scheduled to open on Christmas Day. It's release
was cancelled and then limited by Sony Pictures
because of a recent cyber-attack on Sony Pictures
and because of a vague terrorist threat that
was said to emanate from North Korea. Based
on the media coverage of these events, not
to mention President Obama's denunciation
of Sony for caving into terrorist, my Chinese
Fulbright scholar was expecting a bold and
sophisticated satire, the kind of movie you
can't make in China.
What he got was one part satire, and not very
good satire, to ten parts rectum jokes, boner
jokes, vomit jokes, diarrhea jokes, death
by poison jokes, death by automatic weapons
jokes, severed fingers spurting blood jokes,
tank, helicopter and battle jokes and finally
the biggest joke, Kim's face starting to melt
before his body is engulfed in flame. That's
not even mentioning the profanity, which seemed
to genuinely shock my Chinese visitor. I was
really amazed. He couldn't get over the profanity.
On the way home, I reminded him of a comment
that he'd made when I first spoke with him
in Beijing, which I quoted in my book. He
said, "I don't like censorship but it does
sanitize the image of American in China."
I don't like censorship either and I do not
advocate government control either of the
entertainment industry or of its exports but,
as I will explain in a minute, I see nothing
wrong with urging Hollywood to be more mindful
of the impact some of its products are having
on foreign perceptions of America.
Part three, what is required for a solution?
I'm going to set forth two things which I
think will have to be borne in mind in any
effort to improve America's reputation in
the world. They're both based in time-honored
traditions that are unique to America and
instrumental in her greatness in the world.
Now the first is that public diplomacy conducted
by the government and probably public diplomacy,
I don't think I said this before, simply means
the US government addressing the public in
foreign countries. Not the leaders, not the
diplomats, not elites necessarily, although
elites are included, but also the broader
population, that's why it's called public
diplomacy, that it be based on the truth,
even if that means fighting an asymmetrical
war with our adversaries.
The second requirement is that Americans in
general, and Hollywood in particular, remember
that there's a difference between coercive
state censorship and freely chosen voluntary
restraints on speech by individuals, organizations
and societies. I mean first I'll say quickly
about the public diplomacy part. The propagandists
of Russia, China, Iran, and ISIS and Al Qaeda
and all those other groups pursue a two-pronged
strategy. First they go in for what Joseph
Goebbels called The Big Lie, a false historical
narrative that in all these cases portrays
the United States as the leader of an evil
western conspiracy to subjugate the rest of
the world.
Now when they're faced with evidence that
contradicts their big lie or suspects that
somebody might not be buying their big lie,
they go in, particularly Russia is particularly
good at this, they go in for The Big Confusion,
flooding every available media space with
bizarre rumors, conspiracy theories, paranoid
fantasies, in the hope that their audiences
will simply give up on caring about what really
happened and become cynical and decide there's
no real truth to the matter. It's just everything
is an opinion. Everything's propaganda so
it's all BS and just become very jaded and
cynical.
That's very, very true of Russians and Russian
speakers and Russia's neighbors, neighboring
countries, and the Putin regime is very skilled
at dealing with these very jaded, cynical
populations. It's also trying to build up
the historical narrative of the glory and
wonder of Russia and so forth and rebuild
a kind of idealism. Good luck with that. How
do we respond to this? It's different from
the Soviet Union's Communist ideology which,
of course, itself lost its credence long before
the end of the Cold War.
How do you deal with people who are so confused
and cynical they don't think there's any such
thing as an objective truth or even a basic
fact about the Malaysian Airline that came
down? Nobody knows. Who's going to know? It's
all lies. Do we fight fire with fire and bombard
these populations with counter-propaganda?
This is very tempting to a lot of people,
especially if they haven't been thinking about
it a whole lot. Should we do what comes naturally
to a society where liberty is sacrosanct?
Where liberty is sacrosanct, gather the facts,
articulate the principles at stake and disseminate
them both as forcefully as possible, even
if some aspects of the story do not reflect
well on the United States.
Now there was a time when America got involved
in blatant propaganda, which is to say big
lies. This was before America's entry into
World War I. Perhaps some of you know that
the British were very anxious to get American
involved in the war. The British government
disseminated a great deal of hate propaganda
against the Germans in particular. They fabricated
stories of atrocities committed by the Germans
in Belgium and elsewhere. They were fabrications
and they were widely disseminated.
Even the fledgling movie industry in the United
States got into the act, making films with
titles like, The Hun and The Kaiser, The Beast
of Berlin. I actually saw part of that once.
It's not a very good movie. After World War
I, by the 1930's, both the British and the
American governments realized how much damage
this had done. In the first place, it inspired
Joseph Goebbels and Adolph Hitler. The Big
Lie, hate propaganda, could be done through
modern media. Some of their inspiration came
from what the British had done before World
War I. Other of course came from what the
Soviets were doing.
What the British and Americans did in this
one instance was uncomfortably similar to
what the Soviets and the Nazis had done. The
other damage really bad damage was that when
the first stories began to circulate in Europe
about Nazi atrocities in the 30's, people
didn't believe them because they thought they
had been fabricated. There's a wonderful historian
in Britain who's written a lot about this,
my main source. This is why during World War
II and the Cold War, Britain and America took
the relatively high road.
There was no lack of spying and lying in both
of those conflicts but when it came to communicating
with large foreign populations, both Britain
and America refrained from spreading blatant
lies and disinformation. This is when the
word propaganda lost its neutrality and became
a bad word. Compared with the propaganda of
the Third Reich and the propaganda of the
Soviet Community party, this approach was
decidedly asymmetrical. You know what? It
worked.
Okay last piece. Popular culture. Requirements
for a solution for our popular culture. The
last chapter of my book is full of practical
recommendations. They're still fresh. No one
has taken me up on them although they actually
are being read by a few people in Washington.
For this last piece, I want to say something
about censorship, going back to what I said
earlier. This is the last thing I'll say.
Of course just as the story about The Interview
and Sony was fading from the headlines, at
New Year's we had the attacks on the satirical
weekly Charlie Hebdo in Paris by self-taught
homegrown terrorists and of course on the
kosher supermarket and other targets.
The attack on Charlie Hebdo in particular
inspired a great outcry supporting an absolute
principle of free speech. According to which
all forms of expression, including obscenity,
slander, blasphemy, are acceptable and all
limits on expression, from coercive censorship
to voluntary restraint by individuals and
society are unacceptable. Now the logic here
is that of the slippery slope. Every limit
on speech is defined as perforce a fatal step
on the road to tyranny and the destruction
of freedom. Therefore, no limits on speech
should ever be placed.
Whilst in the outcry was the fact that this
absolute principle has never been upheld by
any society, including modern democratic societies.
Indeed, in every society known to humanity,
there have been limits of some kind on speech.
The real question is why, in spite of this
fact, some societies remain much freer than
others? Here's another thing that was lost
in that outcry. This is the distinction I'm
highlighting for you, which is the distinction
between coercive censorship, in particular
state censorship, legal censorship, and voluntary
restraint.
Now of course some forms of state censorship
and coercion are softer than others. In China,
for example, and Russia, you can just make
one professor disappear and the other professors
will get the hint. My Fulbright friend, one
of his colleagues at the Foreign Studies University
was recently demoted to stacking books in
the library. He taken, his stuff removed from
his office, he's gone. He's not in prison.
As long as he behaves himself, he won't be
in prison. He's in the basement of the building
stacking books in the library. This was somebody
who was teaching classes and talking about
Tiananmen Square and American culture and
film and he's gone. I don't know how my friend
will react frankly.
This is what people mean usually when they
talk about self-censorship. They mean that
a powerful police state or some other overweening
authority has intimidated you into silence.
This is not the same thing as voluntary restraint
in a liberal democracy. Here's the difference.
Voluntary restraint is voluntary. When exercised
by an individual, we call it tact, discretion,
prudence, reticence. When exercised by a society,
we call it custom, propriety, social norms,
public morality.
I think you'll agree with me these days it's
easier to defend individual restraint on speech
than it is to defend social restraints. This
is because social restraints have been roundly
condemned by such champions of free speech,
such as John Stuart Mill, for example. Indeed,
a big part of Mill's argument in his famous
book on liberty is against, "The hostile and
dreaded censorship" of ingrained social attitudes.
From this and many other sources we in the
west have inherited the idea that freedom
depends on letting creative individuals push
the envelope of accepted social norms.
Mill's sharpest critic, James FitzJames Stephen
took issue with this view. His reply to Mill
was simple and commonsensical. It's actually
quite long and complex but he did say some
simple and commonsensical things, one of which
was, "The custom of looking upon certain courses
of conduct with aversion is the essence of
morality." Okay. Here's the problem as I see
it for us. Mill's assumption is now playing
out on a global stage where the decisive battle
over free speech is not being fought between
the creative individual and social conformity.
It's being fought between those who would
defend the fundamental liberties of the west
and those who would destroy them.
To wage that battle, we in the west must do
more than cheer for every gross-out comedy
and in your face publication that comes along.
We must think seriously about the limits that
we do place on speech and expression, why
we place those limits and, most important,
how we place those limits. Here I think America
has a valuable lesson to each Europe. Here
in America, if I paraphrase Will Rogers, "We're
all self-censors, only on different topics."
Consider the vast majority of Americans now
disapprove of derogatory racial and ethnic
epithets. The question is, how did this come
about?
For most Americans this particular restraint
on speech reflects a strong social consensus
that developed slowly over time. We don't
consider it self-censorship most of the time,
except sometimes. Those time are when we feel
intimidated or coerced by someone in authority
not to speak freely. In other words, when
we feel silenced by some imposed rule or law.
It takes a long time for a given restraint
on speech to take hold, to become accepted,
not just by a particular group, an elite,
but by everybody. Because that process is
so slow, people are tempted to speed it up
by passing a law or other coercive measure.
We see this pattern in our American universities
where 40 years ago roughly an informal campaign
began to purge academic discourse of racial
bias, gender bias, disability bias, and every
other conceivable form of bias which, as you
may know, have taken truly elaborate forms
these days. Now this campaign began informally.
It went much too slowly for some of its more
ardent proponents. It also suffered a setback
when critics stuck it with the old Stalinist
label of political correctness. I can still
remember Irving Crystal's wife, Gertrude Himmelfarb,
in 1991 the joy with which she discovered
that phrase, political correctness, because
it captured so much of what she was trying
to criticize about what's going on in academia.
Believe me, that was setback for the politically
correct.
The reaction was predictable and completely
counterproductive. That would be of course
the university speech codes that we now have,
that have been imposed on institutions whose
entire raison d'etre is free inquiry. Now
on a larger scale, you can see the same pattern
in Europe where many countries have so-called
hate speech laws on the books. For example,
in France, where the civil law tradition is
more proscriptive than the Anglo-American
common law tradition, and France also has
no 1st Amendment as you know.
In 1990, the French National Assembly passed
the Gayssot Act, which is one of several Holocaust
denial laws on the books in Europe and of
course also in Israel. A few years later,
France's fundamental press law, which was
passed in 1881, was amended to prohibit hate
speech based on race, religion, gender, and
sexual orientation. Sounds kind of like an
American university, doesn't it? This has
led to many prosecutions of individuals and
publications whose stock in trade is outrageous
speech. One such is Dieudonné, a child of
the Bonheur outside Paris who went from being
a popular comedian working with a Jewish boyhood
friend to being France's most notorious anti-Semite
and Holocaust denier. Another target of these
laws has been the satirical weekly Charlie
Hebdo, which never tires of attacking religion.
Just to cite one example, in 2011, it ran
a cover showing 3 rolls of toilet paper; one
labeled Torah, one labeled Bible, and one
labeled Koran, under the caption, "In the
toilet all the religions." Another cover shows
a rabbi and an SS officer sharing a sloppy
kiss outside the gates of Auschwitz. These
are mild compared to what you find inside
Charlie Hebdo. For example, one image that
was sent to me by a friend in Germany actually
whose brother collects Charlie Hebdos was
an image of Christ committing an act of sodomy
with God. Clearly, Charlie Hebdo is an equal
opportunity offender. However, during the
last decade it has lavished particular venom
on Islam.
In 2013, it ran a two-part series called The
Life Of Mohammed, in which Mohammed is depicted
as a fat, ugly, lecher with a bad case of
priapism displayed in graphic X rated detail.
Now some of the lawsuits brought against Dieudonné
and Charlie Hebdo have won. Others have lost,
forcing the offenders to pay steep fines and
lawyer's fees. All have been decided on fine
points of law, which make little sense to
the public.
For example, France has a law against hate
speech. I know it's after lunch but stay with
me on this. This is a fine point of the law.
France has a law against hate speech based
on religion, but no law against blasphemy.
This means you can trash a fellow citizen
whose beliefs you abhor, no wait, you cannot
trash a fellow citizen whose beliefs you abhor
but you can trash his beliefs.
Now I don't know about you. I'm not a lawyer,
but that looks to me a lot like a hair waiting
to be split. That is precisely the problem
when lawyers and judges and courts regulate
speech, the line between sophistication and
sophistry becomes blurred. The result is,
to judge by what's going on in Europe right
now, is ever uglier and more provocative violations
of the law.
I would close very briefly by contrasting
that with the policy of US newspapers in the
wake of the Danish cartoons and also the Charlie
Hebdo, not to reprint some of these images,
for which they were excoriated. There's actually
a blasphemy law on the books in Massachusetts
from 1697. If the Boston Globe ran one of
these cartoons and they got prosecuted under
that law, the case would get thrown out of
court First Amendment grounds, subsequent
court cases, there's no way you could make
that stick.
That's not why the Globe and other newspapers
in the United States didn't publish those
cartoons. They didn't publish them because
they have a tradition of not publishing material
that is grossly offensive to people's religious
sensibilities. Voluntary restraint. It's a
long-standing custom for which they have been
excoriated for not defending free speech by
publishing some of these cartoons.
I would just close by saying this because
I'm getting a few signals from some of my
supporters here. Something like this, I think.
The world's most robust tradition of free
speech and expression does not consist of
a blanket refusal to set any limits. Rather
it consists of a preference for voluntary
restraint, both individual and communal, over
coercive censorship, especially by the state.
Much as Americans love liberty, we must not
let that love blind us to the importance of
occasionally holding our tongue. Thank you.